Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
This is an example of a lot of what's wrong
with this country.
Now, I'm going to warn you guys.
I'm going to play something that's pretty
ugly.
If there's kids in the room, you may want
to get them out or whatever the case may be
based on your personal sensibilities on this
stuff.
I'm about to play a pretty ugly voicemail
that tells us a lot of what is wrong with
this country.
Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hey, Dave, I'm just calling because
I wanted to become a member.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm not a retard.
Just wondering if you ever listen back to
your shows and and realize how much of a shill
you are and a weak, pathetic man.
Speaker 1: I assume by Shiel he means shill.
Right?
I mean, I just am trying to figure that out.
OK, let me go back, I missed just a few seconds
of that.
Speaker 6: How much of a Shiel you are and
a weak, pathetic man?
Just curious.
Speaker 1: There it is.
So, as you can see, not a particularly substantive
critique.
We get 3000 messages like that every day now,
not voicemails, right, so you've you've got
to look at email, tweets, Facebook posts,
Instagram comments and of course, YouTube
and Twitch comments.
But three thousand a day that are somewhere
in the arena of stuff like that, these are
not folks you can talk sense into.
So we've got to figure out a way to win despite
them.
We're with them is just not realistic.
We've got to win despite them.
And there are a lot of them.
There are a lot of them.
Today on the bonus show, we will talk about
West Nile, positive mosquitoes found in Texas.
What does it mean?
We will also talk about Morgan Stanley.
The company will be banning unvaccinated workers
at their offices starting soon.
We'll talk about why in the legal infrastructure.
And Russia wants to send cosmonauts to China
I'm sorry, to the Chinese space station.
Not the I guess they could go to China, to
the Chinese space station.
We will talk about this possible new outer
space alliance.
And again, I mean, as if we needed more reasons
to invest in space exploration, maybe some
of the right wingers will get behind it because
Russia and China are getting together on the
issue.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at Join Pakman dot com and get instant
access to the.